ac is with us Casey's in Oregon hi Casey
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi babe
hi Rachel thank you so much for taking
my call
sure um so I am calling it today because
I really just graduated with my doctor
pharmacy last week but I am also not
proud to say that I had during that time
period accrued about two hundred and
seventy thousand dollars worth of
student loans for several yeah its eight
years so between my undergrad and
graduate school oh yeah oh my gosh you
graduate last week you graduate last
week congratulations thank you oh thank
you so much yeah I and then that just
not exactly what I pictured for
graduation but well yeah I mean you got
hit you know you it's like woohoo and
getting hit in the face with a snowball
yeah I mean it's like wow exactly oh my
goodness so when do you pass your boards
um so that is what I'm setting for right
now that part is really up in the air
because most of the testing centers are
closed they're not doing them virtual
interesting um no so they do not allow
any virtual testing some of the testing
centers are slowly starting to open good
but do you have a job lined up when you
pass I actually before you even passing
I have a job lined up so I have my
residency starting July 1st and I'll be
making about 54,000 but that's only a
one-year kind of contract continuing
education thing but at least it says
it's a job you have a one-year residency
yes that seems long I thought most of
pharmacy students I talked to have gone
straight to work I didn't is having an
Oregon thing or am I missing something
no so uh what's the pharmacy degree you
can kind of jump right into working of
how its kind of working now as most of
your retailer community setting
pharmacies will allow you to do that
I'm so going into your Walmart Walgreens
I kind of think but as you're hoping to
do any type of hospital related pharmacy
did you have to have a residency so a
little bit over there training okay but
a pace double
yes we're making a hundred 235 that I'm
talking to decision right yes and that's
oh if you're going straight into it so
once I've done with this on your
residency I will be making that 100 to
135 but again kind of taking that
getting a job that I think I would like
more I do take that pickup for a year
can you do the residency later it is a
possibility although I already accepted
the position so that's a $60,000 $70,000
expense you just took on with the
$270,000 student loan bill so that's
what's concerning me I'd want to be
making some money and attacking the
student loans and then maybe go back and
do my residency yeah most of the
residents if you wait it's most likely
like a year waiting so I could take a
year off it that's that's correct yeah
and then from there it's because I see
the job because you're taking the MD or
I'm sorry you're taking the you're doing
the residency for a year because the job
that you're gonna want is one that you
want more long-term than going into a
different type of field so the question
when you finish residency what would you
be making in your field the same thing
so so I mean if I was in your shoes yeah
I mean honestly I would probably pause
the residency just go get a job for
three years of one that yeah you don't
love it it's still in your field though
and you're getting that those reps and
you're able to pay this off because if
you're making 130 right right away I
mean I'd live on nothing do that for
about three years
do the student loans and then take the
year of the 50 grand because you'll have
actually no payments at that point and
then go because those because this is a
long-term decision for you so for the
short term I would on almost just rather
make the sacrifice make some money and
we go back to the residency otherwise
you're just basically putting the
majority of your debt reduction on hold
yet another year and so graduation
doesn't mean much to your 270 it's still
sitting there oh by the way you get to
paint on it after six months anyway they
don't I don't think resident well might
be residency will qualify for keeping
the student loans on home pause I don't
know if it will or not but why
I would be chomping at the bit to get my
income up if I was you sir that's why
I'm thinking about this but if you go
this route you know you're just gonna
have a obviously you'll be putting a lot
less for one year on to the debt than
you would if you went a different route
and that's why we're springing to action
on the math for you but uh Wow Wow Wow
very deep very deep thanks for the call